hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades you've most likely clicked on
this video as you're about to start Red
Dead Redemption to remembering the
stories of Red Dead Redemption 1 and the
legend of red hollow in Red Dead
Revolver maybe a little hazy let's break
them down and get up-to-date with
everything red dead related before the
narrative begins let's get the time
frames in order first Red Dead Revolver
is set in the 1880s with Red Dead
Redemption set 20 to 30 years later in
1911 Red Dead Redemption 2 begins in
1899 so we'll break down John Marston
story before we tackle red hollows
journey rites introductions out of the
way let's do this
it's 1911 and John Marston arrives in
Blackwater an outlaw in FBI custody with
a single very specific task to complete
to take down a criminal gang led by the
notorious outlaw Dutch van der Linde
first question why send an outlaw to
take down an outlaw well that's simple
John was a member of Dutchess gang until
1904 when he was left for dead by his
brothers in arms' the FBI's bargaining
chip is John's wife and son Abigail and
Jack preying on John's desire to live a
normal law for life with his family the
FBI and in particular this guy Edgar
Ross were the puppet masters controlling
John's future and his hopes for
redemption for all his wrongdoings the
FBI know of six surviving members of the
van der Linde gang John Abigail and Jack
who have already accounted for and three
more track down and kill Bill Williamson
Xavier escuela and the leader Dutch van
der Linde these are the final days of
the Wild West the Bureau are keen to
take down the last remaining outlaws and
let the modernization replace the cowboy
lifestyle horses will be replaced by
cars the telephone will replace the
telegram trains will link the entire
country this is a period of change John
driven by his desire to save his family
and lived that lawful life quickly
tracks down Bill Williamson don't make
me kill you
nobody needs to kill anyone bill
oh poor well that didn't go to plan
right off the bat our hero is left to
die vultures are circling but a random
act of kindness gets this story back on
track Bonnie McFarlane miss Bannock
Bonnie McFarlane selfless act can't be
understated as John regains his health
and well-being
he helps Bonnie out on the McFarland
ranch until he's fit enough to go after
bill once again the next step of John's
journey is to visit the sheriff over in
armadillo you scratch my back I'll
scratch yours seems to be the way of the
Old West all right tell you what let's
go deal with them hoods in the saloon
then we'll discuss Williamson John meets
another chap this guy mr. West Dickens
mr. nigel west dickens a snake-oil con
man who tricks his audience into buying
items from his wagon John even becomes a
stooge in return for Nigel's help along
with this freak who seems to be Gollum
from the Lord of the Rings goodbye John
Marston it's been a great pleasure
almost everyone John has helped up to
this point team up and break into Fort
Mercer and as you've guessed it bill
isn't there let's go get to make morning
forget him Xavier squalor he's gone to
see Xavier squalor John travel south and
crosses the border into Mexico Mexico is
amidst an uprising and revolution is in
the air
on one hand abraham Reyes wants to take
the country back from the militarized
government and the government led by
Colonel a nd want to maintain their grip
and stay in power and the luxuries
associated with that here we find London
Ricketts a famous gunslinger living out
his retirement in Mexico John recognizes
him from the stories he was told as a
child and a young adult and immediately
trusts and idolizes London yeah killing
means a strange kind of Fame I was the
fastest in my time I must have been I'm
the only one left London acts like a
father figure to John keeping him aware
of his actions allowing John to be open
about his past and the terrible deeds he
went through during his gang
is born in a whorehouse often at a young
age John did everything and anything to
survive including joining a notorious
and deadly gang but now he only wants to
see his family again and teach his son
how to be a good man on the right side
of the law John plays a dangerous game
in Mexico joining both the rebel cause
and the government's ideals although he
never really cares for the political
nature of it all he simply wants
information about Xavier and Bill
morally John doesn't really care for
either side and begins to play both
sides against each other assisting the
military one moment and thwarting them
in the name of revolution the next
finally Colonel IND hands over the
information about Williamson and escuela
and more importantly their location
flanked by the Mexican military John is
equipped to take down both of his gang
mates however there's a sting in this
tale
it's a bloody trap a double-cross and
John will be killed momentarily but
that's not the way this tale ends John
may not believe in the revolution but
the revolution leads in John Raees and
the rebels arrive and stop John's
execution by the way this is how I got
my revenge
think he's dead with this added momentum
John finds bill and Xavier and kills are
in prisons both depending on your play
style but there's no doubt both are
killed by the FBI either way and now
only one man stands in John's way to
Redemption Dutch van der Linde and as if
by magic video game logic he's been
spotted back across the border we have
reason to believe there that van der
Linde is in the area the city our
journey began in Blackwater is the same
place we returned to for the final act
of Red Dead Redemption we'd expect Dutch
to be alone as the last remaining member
of the gang but Dutch has this
infectious personality and outlook on
America which has brought others to his
side in the same way Dutch built his
first band of outlaws with the use of
the nation who were shunned by American
ideals he's now doing the same with the
Native Americans the oppressed that
belittled he takes the downtrodden and
gives them belief in a better future a
future to fight for the skills Dutch
gives his followers shapes them as
adults and in John's case allows him to
track down and although he obviously
admires Dutch he has no qualms in
killing the man he once considered akin
to a father with funds running low Dutch
robs a bank in Blackwater it's nice to
see you John hello Dutch have the girl
yeah the easy Dutch she's a parting gift
from me that bullet to the innocent head
of a bank teller further alienates John
from his mentor and shows us that Dutch
just like John is willing to kill to
reach his goals
the final battle sees Dutch and his new
gang take on the combined might of the
FBI the US Army and of course John Dutch
just didn't stand a chance and before
the end the two share one last piece of
dialogue his chilling last message
should be heeded by off when I'm gone
they'll just find another monster
[Music]
John's task is now over and surprisingly
Edgar Ross keeps his word John returns
home to Abigail and Jack and even uncle
makes an appearance
the mastan's build a strong relationship
with John attempting to make his son a
better man than him constantly pushing
him away from crime and instead focusing
him on ranch work sitting by campfires
with fellow travelers John is now able
to once again enjoy the world he lives
in keenly listening to the stories of
history and legend one story in
particular stands out the story of Red
Hollow and his quest for vengeance for
his father you heard of that red harlot
that stood out to every man who blocked
his path Mexican army included nearly
cost him his life but he read is said to
have defeated the greatest gunslinger in
history mr. Kelly and thus ascended into
folklore but hold that thought we'll
look at Reds history very soon back on
the ranch everything is falling into
place John and Abigail have left their
former lives behind and work hard to
prosper on the right side of the law
jack is becoming a strong-minded young
man but nothing ends well in Red Dead
Redemption
sadly the FBI and once again that man
had Garos aren't prepared to let John
live out his days bring in the US Army
and the bureau's best men to terminate
the real last standing member of
Dutchess gang John's final hours have
begun in his last embrace with the
family he fought to save John sends
Abigail and Jack away now it's John's
last and a former outlaw trying to
change his past I love you
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
John's death impacts jack greatly for
the next three years
Abigail raised Jack single-handedly but
after her sudden passing Jack must make
a decision
to continue on the ranch as his parents
wanted or to follow in his father's
footsteps
Jack chooses revenge he became an outlaw
filled with vengeance and a single quest
in life to avenge his father's death and
killed those responsible in the final
few moments of Red Dead Redemption Jack
Marston finally tracks down Edgar Ross
who has now retired and killed the man
who double-crossed his father Jack went
on to continue his father's good deeds
and re-establish the master name in the
last days of the Old West so we have an
understanding of John's quest for
redemption and that's the end of his
story but Red Dead follows more than a
single outlaw we'll have to see what
kind of man John really is in Red Dead
Redemption too
maybe just maybe we'll see things
differently through Arthur's eyes but
Red Dead story of the Wild West predates
Arthur and begins in the 1870s with a
young boy named red Harlow the son of a
miner
Nate and his wife falling star a Native
American the family are poor but that
all changes in the opening scene when
Nate and his partner discover a gold
mine but red is more interested in the
pistol his father now owns our troubles
are finally over we hit a vein of gold
as wide as a locomotive that runs clean
through Bear Mountain hey pop where'd
you get that didn't see you for you yeah
can I hold it she's one of a pair only
two in the whole world where's the other
one My partner Griff has it we made them
up special to symbolize our newfound
wealth
can I try it out
one day this vine weapon will be yours
but for now I want to take my own pistol
without warning a gang of Raiders attack
Reds home he fights alongside his father
until they can't fight anymore both his
mother and father are no longer of this
world they're killer gloats until red
makes his move
[Music]
severing the killer's arm from his body
but badly burning his own hand in the
process hiding in the brush read
survives now orphaned he was all alone
around twelve years passed and read
Hollow
now looking like wood why did it be I
said Clint Eastwood Clint stupid swear
box red has learned to handle a gun
even with his severely burned and
scarred hand and he's now ready to make
his mark on the world whilst passing
through widow's patch red notices a
group of bandits have taken over the
town and to top it off he sees this red
runs riot and freeze the town from his
villainous group but to collect his
bounty
he must escort sheriff O'Grady to
brimstone red cannot catch a break as
Bandit attempt to rob the train to
brimstone
but our hero saves the passengers in
style by the way I don't know why I
choose to shoot people in the groin so
much I think I have issues now in
brimstone sheriff Bartlett convinces red
to become a bounty hunter and sends him
to kill the bodies found in the West
including circus freaks with a fetish
for dynamite oh and in this mission it's
the first time we meet Jack Swift a
British bank robber and shaft shooter
who escaped England to gain fame in
America remember him for later read
continues to take down every bounty he's
handed even killing a woman who said
chivalry was dead his final victim is
mr. black who has a Gatling gun inside a
copy and look how he dies nicely done so
it's now time for red to pick up all the
gold he's old but of course there's an
issue we have a small problem in the
bank we meet Annie Stokes who is being
run out of her ranch by Governor Griffin
red travels to Annie's ranch which has
just been attacked by Griffin's men in
return for a little information red
tells Annie about a battle royale
tournament coming up and the five
thousand gold coin winnings will help
Annie keep her farm 5,000 pieces in gold
this will help me keep my range and by
Battle Royale I don't mean fortnight I
mean a real jewel guns in holsters
quick-draw a back in brimstone red is
involved in a bar fight after
overhearing a story of a man with one
arm yeah you remember him
he's called Colonel Darren by the way by
the end of the bar fight red is arrested
by the sheriff who looks dumb scared of
him I said hand it over
during his time in prison the sheriff
reveals some history to read Nate his
father had a partner called Griff who
made a deal with a military leader
called Diego to save his own skin but
ultimately sentenced Nate to death I
only own half the claim my partner Nate
owns the other half and what if I kill
your partner
then that would make us
partners
partner sheriff Bartlett releases red
who immediately tracks down Diego and
his train of murder red absolutely
wrecks everyone until he's taken down by
that one-armed man again they spare him
for some ridiculous reason and once
again he's locked in prison remember
earlier when we said that Reds mother
was Native American well luckily for her
red has a cousin called shadow wolf who
watched his assault and sets out to save
him
meanwhile in prison red meat buffalo
soldier a former slave who joins in the
cause buffalo soldier makes it back to
brimstone to inform the governor who
places him in yet another prison cell
that's not for now is it for I think
worked for pers themself back over to
red and shadow the one-armed man from
red childhood stands in their way but
the duo prevail and have revenge for
Red's father but at what cost go cousin
finish what you have started
in a touching moment red and beds Wolf's
knife into Colonel Darrin's chest to
give him the credit father kill our
people now shall know of your courage
cousin red is now in full rage mode and
takes down Diego's war train and another
part of his revenge plan is complete
diego attempts to bargain the same way
Nate's partner Griff did 12 years
earlier but red he's not driven by
wealth and greed it doesn't interest him
what do you see back in Brin stow the
Battle Royale is about to begin and red
can't turn down the challenge from mr.
Kelly I would very much look forward to
beating an adversary of your talent the
Battle Royale begins and our hero's red
Jack and Annie progressed unscathed red
even takes down a character based on
Billy the Kid the final four combatants
in the Battle Royale are confirmed the
aforementioned red jack Annie and the
current champion mr. Kelly red and Kelly
meet in the first semi-final semi-final
a semi however you'd like to say due to
the sudden absence of sheriff Bartlett
I'm gonna be stepping in to oversee this
up conclusion to the battle royale now
whereas the two gentlemen before us are
clearly the best I believe a change of
the rules is in order I hereby
disqualified Jack Swift and Anna Stokes
the winner of this here round is going
to be the winner of the Battle Royale
the semi-final just became the final
[Applause]
[Music]
the second red wins governor Griffin
turns on red and suddenly everything
falls into place red you're good I'll
give you that but of course you'd have
to be to live through what you did
still I'm afraid that we're gonna have
to end right here and now what we should
have been did so many years ago didn't
she a beauty
yeah can I hold that she's one of a pair
only two in the whole world
where's the other one the other one
before red campus you the governor mr.
Kelly arises to fight to the death red
wins because of course he does and now
it's time for the final faceoff with
Governor Griffin tell me where to find
him his mansion but it's secured like a
fortress it'll be hard even for a bounty
hunter like you he will not be alone he
ain't the only one who wants the
governor
I reckon that their prize money is in
that mansion of his our three heroes
battled past hundreds of henchmen
released buffalo soldier from his prison
cell and finally red and Buffalo track
down the governor who outsmarts the
jewel leaving Buffalo pinned to the
ground
no one's lifting that that man is a dead
man and now the final faceoff red versus
the governor the end is here oh sorry of
course the big bad guy needs a monologue
first I always regretted what happened
back on your daddy's farm red I should
have been there
to make sure you join them but lucky for
me I get a second chance
okay so that was really anticlimactic
but the deed is now done never didn't
like him much red must run become an
outlaw to survive
he killed the governor and will be
hanged for certain oh look
Buffalo Soldier is still alive dummy how
strong is Annie oh well from video games
the sheriff gives the five thousand in
gold to red who turns it down only
claiming the revolver from his dead
enemy his final words are a lesson to us
all give it to them
[Music]
it never was about the money
[Music]
it was never about the money bread'
Hollow was never seen again the man
became a legend and his stories filled
the final days of the Wild West
will he reappear in Red Dead Redemption
to Wheeljack Swift to be the reason John
Marston called his son Jack
so many questions but now we have a
beginning to the Red Dead story and we
have a heart crushing ending now let's
learn what happened in between I hope
you all enjoy Red Dead Redemption - I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure see you next time
[Music]